hallo und herzlich willkommen aus einer
etwas anderen position in meinem zimmer
sonstige das ganze immer von hier aber
da ich heute ein tor mache was ihr schon
im titel wahrscheinlich sehen konntet
will ich das ganze von der anderen seite
machen so wie jetzt ist als wenn ich
reinkommen würde ich entschuldige mich
erst mal dafür dass ich total fertig
aussehen ist meine augen rot sind dass
ich auch nur so nur auf 15 jahren
gezogen bin so ein bisschen schwierig
weil ich war gestern beim holly festival
habe mir dabei auch sehr weh getan und
zwar wenn ihr euch das mal und ich habe
hier überall so richtige wunden und
pflaster über all das tut alles heftig
werden nämlich in brennnesseln gefallen
und bin dann auch einfach mal ein
bisschen liegengeblieben weil ich halt
wenn ich oft gestanden während dann mit
den händen da direkt darauf gefasst
hätte dann werden meine hände glaub ich
komplett kaputt die sind doch ein
bisschen kaputt aber es geht halt alles
noch jedenfalls zu meiner ganzen beide
wäre meine reaktion hat ein kumpel von
mir sogar wunderschön gefilmt hast du
das gesehen
luca was immer du hast du das gefühl
mich da rein gefallen weil du weißt du
was
ein erster fahrer jedenfalls bin ich
halt wenig ganzen sachen so ein bisschen
fertig das tut mir leid ich finde es
total traurig dass ich trotzdem heute
ein video machen muss weil es ist der
kontakt nicht mehr den pünktlich bringt
aber ich würde sagen direkt an mit der
winter bevor ich hier noch mal länger
einfach um quatsche macht das ganze mal
so dass ich das einfach so zeige ich
hoffe ich zeige dir nicht zu viel sonst
bitte ich euch dass ihr mich da nicht
stoppt oder irgendwas macht hier sehen
wir erst mal das ist meine schmutz ecke
da kommt alles hin sowie leere flaschen
oder so meisten stehen der bionade oder
flaschen ich liebe bionade wir nehmen
eine freude machen wollte und mit
bionade holunder und dann einfach so
sagen die gewaschenen ist in diesem fall
jetzt ein t shirt und by autobahn können
wir hier ein wenig weiter umgehen hier
befindet sich dann mein bettchen this is
the magic happens
davor stehen rucksack und eine tasche
von mir die ich halt immer im
unternehmen gerecht werden business
mäßig zur schule und so wo ich nicht
hingehe oder uni halt und rucksack hat
es hier halt so mein nachttisch bereich
da steht immer eine wasserflasche oder
halt bionade war ich hatte wollte jetzt
nicht alles so richtig krass auf
freundliche ich habe ein bisschen
aufgeräumt aber ich wollte es meist
eigentlich so lassen wie es ist weil ich
finde für den router aufzurollen ein
bisschen doof es sollte so sein wie es
immer normal auch ist und deswegen ist
ganz schön dann hier habe ich so sachen
wie sport wurden über liegen ein schrank
macht mal ganz schnell hier guck doch an
wunderschön wenn man richtig zu viel
preisgeben können auch pause war's egal
hier ist halt so was wie boxershorts so
was alles ist mein ipad was immer noch
einen akzent hat fast immer noch auf
einem handtuch
hier eine kleine unechte pflanze um so
ein bisschen hat grünes hier
einzubringen
dahinter sieht ihr so ein paar bücher
wie beispielsweise zurück in die weite
welt von carlsberg dass minecraft buch
oder sowas wie studierende sollen kochen
lernen
also oder ein wörterbuch so das ist das
einzige was ich so lese ich ist auch
eine tolle youtube auszeichnung das
steht drauf dass ich unter 1000
abonnenten erreicht hat ist supertoll
und so bonbons habe ich auch mal im bett
das ist so gegen halsschmerzen und die
kamera endlich mal nutzen damit der als
besser geht
dann habe ich dann eben auch immer so
eine kleine box wo ich sein ladekabel
hier habe für mein iphone ein
wunderschönes hinwies dass du leider
kaputt von mir aber egal
dann ist das wiso mein bett mit meinem
bettbezug und da habe ich so ein bild
von manhattan seid keine ahnung 34
jahren hin dass taschen und überall hier
so ein paar kids vs muss ich da mal
hinsetzen und trugen auch an diesem
bereich kennt ihr wahrscheinlich schon
aus meinem setup video und zwar ist das
mein arbeitsplatz mehr oder weniger ich
arbeite ja nicht vollzeit youtube ich
bin ja studierende und ja mittlerweile
studieren dort nicht mehr schüler und
das ist quasi wo ich hier alles
aufnehmen hier befindet sich ein kleiner
tisch direkt daneben im magen spürt man
so ein bisschen das ist alles ein
bisschen gerade in einer phase wo es zu
einer krankheit über geht jedenfalls aus
dem kleinen tisch wo ich so ein paar
schreibt sachen drauf wieder diese bons
überall rumliegen die als islam los die
sind ganz cool eigentlich mein ipod nano
mit dem ich auf dem ich sehr viele mixas
drauf habe und damit immer so ein
bisschen höre meine caps habe ich glaube
schon gesagt eine tui dann befindet sich
hier meine beiden mischpult bzw einen
kompressor mischpult und mehr normal ist
mit spult das ganze geht dann hier in
mein mikrofon dass sich hier darunter
schenken kann und dann nehme ich auf das
alles softbox hier ist zurzeit noch so
eine provisorische rampe deswegen nicht
rechts immer so ein bisschen geld
beleuchtet weil die insel waren für
leuchtet gelb und die leuchtet weiß da
muss ich mir mal ich war mit zwei neue
holen ich habe auch hier schon ganz
viele sachen auf geschrieben die ich mir
kaufen muss als neues equipment und da
muss ich dann mal langsam zu schlagen
damit das ganze ein bisschen besser
angezogen
das ist halt ein z wie gesagt das hat
sich nicht verändert
da die zeit immer noch einen imac und
samsung als zweiter bildschirm
dann habe ich auf der rechten seite den
links ist immer so alles aufgeräumt und
rechts immer so steht dann also um
in meinem macbook air auch schon
mittlerweile 34 jahre alt mit meinen
kopfhörern drauf hier dieses pflaster er
das tut alles weh mit meiner depression
netbooks es ist die beste
von diesen kleinen boxen die es gibt
also da gibt es keine bessere kostet
noch dementsprechend 120 150 oder soll
dann sehen wir da ganz viele rechnungen
die man halt so sammelt so
beispielsweise wenn man sich schuhe
kauft oder so was alles auch hier immer
was zu trinken am start ladekabel vom
macbook einfach so sachen die ich halt
so alltäglich benutze mein macbook wenn
ich wieder draußen ist nämlich immer das
macbook trinken tue ich auch täglich und
die box benutzt beispielsweise auch
täglich ist wenn sich alles täglich was
hier darauf liegt ja dann bekommen wir
zu meinen müll aber erst mal dass mein
kleiner müller und ihr und deshalb ein
bisschen kabel gewöhnt aber ich habe das
ganze minimalistisch zu halten
dann kommen wir hier meinen beiden
kleider stühlen also ihnen die einfach
mal so dass es eigentlich falls freude
da sind und man irgendwie hier vorträgen
des wenn man dessen schild kann man sich
den stuhl oder den stuhl einfach hierhin
schieben und kann man kann sich auch
grundsätze und aufs bett sehr viele
sitzmöglichkeiten das longboard dann im
fernsehen gucken oder karat und was
machen
jedenfalls habe ich da drauf sehr oft
meine sachen einfach liegen die ich
morgen anziehe am nächsten tag hier
liegt ja jetzt gerade einfach alles
mögliche was ich im video jetzt nicht so
gehen wir über rumliegen wollte haben
tun also t shirts pullover hosen
pullover und t shirt dann ist hier liegt
der ordner wo ich immer alle dinge
sammeln also rechnungen kontoauszüge so
was alles möglich gehalten dann sehen
wir hier eine goldene nase hochziehen
ich bin halt nicht auf dem weg zur
krankheit er das ist ein bisschen
traurig dann sehen wir hier eine lampe
die ich auch an machen kann weil mich
manchmal gefragt ob ich damit sterne
beobachtet oder irgendwie sowas nie das
ist denn jetzt mal lampe ja dann haben
wir meine kamera die canon eos 600d mit
dem mikrofon drauf und mit dem tisch mit
dem start bringen
ja hier auch wieder so ein bisschen was
grün ist alles unecht weil das sonst als
bei mir sterben würde
da ist meine brille dann siehst du sonst
ja alle nicht drin
und dann sind hier also sachen wie hier
sind jetzt viele kabel taschenrechner
wäre so was alles mögliche und sauger
mit kabeln jetzt auch alles voll mit
kabeln und headset und usb sticks
hier ist alles vom playstation spielen
hier sieht die playstation spiele ich
überhaupt haben wird das ist so voll ist
alles hier folgende playstation spielt
und die ist schon hoch die schublade und
ich hab ich mir was unter 16 teams aber
nicht tiefer glaube ich bei der nintendo
3ds spiele konsole sehr erfahrene
irgendwie paris ihre ich liebe diese
fußbälle von ikea damit kann man einfach
im letzten lauf über spielen beide
kopfhörer noch da bin ich halt und
fernseher ein ganz ganz alter sony
bravia richtig dickes ding ist ein
scheiß fans heraus müssen halt not groß
dann haben wir hier auch noch meine
beiden controller ich habe einen
schwarz-roten eine brille die ich
gestern auf die festival gefunden habe
davon hey ich wiege mich da drin
ich kann ja mal ein paar fotos gerade
einwänden von holly festival jedenfalls
es hier dann so meine ecke wo ich quasi
wirklich alles reinschmeißen liegt
sachen wieder schalke
karte im stadion mal meine alten
kopfhörer media markt über fernbedienung
einfach taschentücher zeitungsartikel
quasi alles mögliche drin so hula ketten
nicht alte zeitschriften plastiktüten
alles möglich aber auch zum teil auch
weil ich sehr sehr auf die nase putzen
muss und hier liegt mein schatz mein
wlan meine playstation steht dahinter
eine playstation 3 ps3 hier meine erste
spielerin das explodiert schon hier
langsam da sind nicht viele spiele und
und hier so eine kleine kiste der ist
ein bisschen gewöhnst darin bat stifter
und so und hier sind so sachen tabletten
die demos ist es einfach gegen meine
erkältung die hier gerade an bahnen
durch ein weiter blick genommen und
sonst
hier mein long dort könnt ihr euch denn
sonst noch zeigen hier sind noch handeln
mit denen ich eigentlich nicht sehr viel
mache aber man muss ja sportlich sein
aber meine ganze wundern tut so weh und
hier habe ich halt so was meine
sporttasche auch noch zwei davon eine
kündigung weil ich im fitnessstudio
könige war ich dann in hamburg ins
fitnessstudio gehe ja das sind auch
sportschuhe drin und dann so ein
handtuch halt immer fürs fitnessstudio
oder fußball oder wenn man die
allgemeinheit sport noch oder so und
sonst würde ich sagen er ist auch ein
spiegel
hallo na da kann man sich halt angucken
und sonst würde ich sagen dass das das
eigentlich das ist mein zimmer oder ich
weiß ja wie denken vergesse ich zeig
doch mal wenn man quasi so reingeht
sieht so aus meiner ecke der meinen
schrank dann mein bett kommode mein bett
einen rucksäcke mein schreibtisch
arbeitsplatz hobby berufsarbeit
dingsbums youtube das wo ich meine
ganzen klamotten im park und stühle
meine sportsachen hier unten ein gaming
fernseher als alles meine sehr schöne
steinwand ich finde ich sehr schön sehr
sehr schön und
das war es dann auch eigentlich schon
von meinem zimmer habe die kultur als
extra bisschen später noch zu kurz bevor
ich jetzt umziehen paar wochen monaten
in zwei drei monaten
und dann kann ich dann noch mal ein
update machen weil ich hätte glaube ich
hat sich mal wenn ich das hier schon von
einem jahr gemacht hätte was hat sich so
viel verändert zum beispiel die wände
waren vor allem weil diese steine und
war nicht da der fernseher stand voll
war anders der schreibtisch dann vorher
nicht so sondern der stadt so und als
wirklich und hier sind halt übrigens
auch noch vorhänge die ihre die ganze
zeit seht da habe ich extra vorgezogen
weil das ist eine ganz große glasfront
und da will ich halt nicht dass man da
dann bei uns so in den kleinen das
kleine kärtchen gucken kann wenn ich
nicht so toll
die folge sei eigentlich ganz cool dass
sie auch wenn du die zu hassen es immer
noch nicht reinkommt das fürs aufnehmen
super geeignet aber schlafen will und
dann zum beispiel ich schlafe bis 12 uhr
oder so dann wird man teilweise schon um
9 uhr wach weil das einfach so hell ist
aber ich hab's einfach damit überspielt
dass ich so ein schlafmittel habe dass
ich nicht von irgendetwas gedeckt werden
kann
und natürlich sagen dass maria und klaus
mit fischer erzeugt gefallen hat und
eventuell solche com tage mögt zeigt
dass wir mit einem mag ich schreibe
immer die kommentare was sie am coolsten
findet an meinem zimmer urlaub ist total
scheiße findet und dann würde ich sagen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
bei dem nächsten video was ihr von mir
angucken werdet was mache ich hier